in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about catalysts so let's
first imagine that we have two reactants
and I'm going to simplify things with
these overly simplified drawings so
let's say you have this reactant right
over here and I'm drawing it that way
for a reason and then I let's say I have
this reactant that looks something like
this and obviously if we're talking
about a chemical reaction we're not
usually talking about just two different
molecules we're talking talking about
many trillions of molecules that are
often times in some form of a solution
but here we're just giving an example of
one of each types of the reactant
molecules so let's imagine that if they
are able to run into each other with
sufficient energy and with the right
orientation they're going to bond with
each other so these two reactants would
react to form this product that looks
like this and obviously as I mentioned
this is a
oversimplification but it gives you the
general idea so it might form a molecule
that looks like that now as we mentioned
it has to have the right energy and the
right orientation so we can think about
this in terms of an energy diagram right
over here where in this axis let's call
the uh
progress progress of
reaction and in this
axis let's just say
energy
energy now we have our reactants that
are at a certain energy level when they
are left to their own devices but if you
if they have enough energy added to the
system they are able to react and then
then after they react the product will
have a certain energy so this is a
reaction where we've had to put energy
into the reaction because the products
have a higher energy than the reactants
so this is the prod in this case there's
just one product let's just call it
products and let's call this
reactants now this hump over here where
we have to put even more energy than we
end up with our products at the end we
call that the activation energy the
energy that you need in order to make
this reaction happen from left to right
so let's this right over here is the
activation
energy
energy now I said that this video was
going to be about catalysts what does a
catalyst do well a catalyst can lower
the activation energy for a reaction
it's not a part of the reaction you
could view it as a bystandard it's
something that that's helping the
reaction happen it's not getting used up
in the reaction it's not getting
produced in the reaction it's just
helping the reaction happen and it would
help it by lowering that activation
energy so if you have the presence of a
catalyst it might look something like
this so all of a sudden you need less
energy to get over this hump and to form
the products now what could a catalyst
actually be that does that well we could
think about biological systems where
common catalyst is an enzyme or enzy
times and one way that they lower the
activation energy it could be providing
a surface where the reactants can react
it could be to Pro make it a little bit
easier for them to get in the right
orientation so for example imagine if
you had a huge enzyme that looked
something like this and this once again
is a Hu is an
oversimplification and it just happened
to be that this part of the enzyme it's
it's able to bond to that first reactant
let me do that same color to that first
reactant and puts it into the right
orientation where this other part of the
enzyme can bond with that second
reactant and puts it in the right
orientation so that you don't need quite
as much energy for them to be able to
react with each other and you might say
well why do we even need these or why
are enzymes even important remember
enzymes are type of catalyst well it
turns out that your body or many
biological systems need a lot of
reactions to occur but without a
catalyst and in this case in a
biological system without an enzyme the
temperature would have to be too high
where all sorts of other bad things will
happen but by having catalysts in this
case an enzyme it allows the reaction to
proceed in this case from left to right
without having the energy be so high
that it's damaging to the system as a
whole so it's a labeled to have this
reaction happen at a lower energy or
this biological system at a lower
temperature